après l'hiver interminable le
traditionnel temps des sucres le temps
de se mettre un peu de printemps dans la
bouche
derrière les sourires
l'inquiétude ce temps des sucres est
peut être le dernier pour la famille
varin d'oka
car comme une centaine d'autres
producteurs ils sont en guerre avec ceux
qui les représentent
la fédération des producteurs acéricoles
du québec et on est pris en otage
définitivement la presse c'est ça vous
avez entendu parler des contrevenants
des filous c'est nous depuis quelques
années la fédération a saisi des
centaines de milliers de livres de sirop
chez ces contrevenants
une soixantaine de litiges entre les
producteurs et la fédération sont devant
les tribunaux et depuis que la sève
coule
la fédération a même installé des gardes
de sécurité dans certaines cabanes de
producteurs qui refusent de rentrer dans
le rang
c'est le cas ici chez les goudrons de
scotstown le fait que chaque goutte
d'eau au début des années 2000 le marché
du sirop s'effondre
québec doit dépenser 40 millions $ pour
sauver les producteurs pour éviter que
le problème ne se reproduise la
fédération hôte en 2002 et non sans
controverse pour une mise en marché
collective
bon je vais le volet
liberté le produit est un détail et de
produits commandés glisseront avec le
grain depuis les producteurs doivent
livrer leurs six roues à la fédération
qu'ils entreposent et le vent ils ne
peuvent eux en vendre qu'à certaines
conditions et selon des quotas
déterminés les producteurs doivent aussi
payer un prélever une taxe de 12 cents
la livre
deux véhicules cela fait grincer des
dents une minorité producteurs c'est moi
qu'ils le montrent et ce patente lolo
pourquoi se faire que je gagnerais des
redevances à quelqu'un qui a jamais rien
fait pour moi qu'on compare le suivre de
la boulaye colloque est aujourd'hui un
émissaire de la fédération est venu
négocier avec les goudrons ils refusent
depuis plus de trois ans de payer leur
prélever mais surtout ils veulent vendre
eux-mêmes leur sirh où on se bat pour le
principe ici au québec on devrait avoir
le droit de produire la fédération s'est
avoué prévente qu'elle le soit laquelle
qu'on ait le choix
le on aider face à des gens qui ont
profité mais vraiment profité de
l'amélioration des périples des volumes
qu'on fait dans le sirop d'érable mais
qui veulent pas accepter les légères
contraintes que ça prouve au niveau 2
des privés pour nouveau l'organisation
de la mise en marché ce taux si la cause
des récalcitrants n'est même pas le
vice-président de la fédération c'est
parce qu'ici on est convaincu que l'
agence de vente a fait des petits
miracles ya 15 ans le marché du sirop
québec ça peut-être 15 millions
le prix aussi à tripler si les
producteurs vendaient leurs six roues à
un dollar la livre au début des années
2000 ils en obtiennent aujourd'hui de
dollars 75
si bien qu'en dix ans le québec a perdu
10% de parts de marché au profit ses
voisins on parle du terrain parce que
ont aussi mis des barrières tout autour
de nous on s'est mis des barrières a dit
nous autres on y le plus grand
producteur de sirop d'érable qui on veut
contrôler sûr mais mais mais mais le
nouveau brunswick l'ontario et andy
warhol que si on est capable
les récalcitrants évoquera aussi le
droit à la singularité du goût car le
sirop de la fédération est le plus
souvent un sirop en vrac production soit
3 à 4 ans soit dans une banque de ce
héros comme la chaux avec géo avec des
différends à gauche et sert aussi comme
un vassal à plusieurs gousset c'est ce
qui est intéressant mais on peut plus
avoir ce camp qui est envoyer la bot je
peux accomplir
c'est marche ou crève si les varin
perdent leur cause devant la régie des
marchés agricoles
il envisage de fermer l'entreprise
familiale les goudrons eux sont acculés
à la faillite en appoint fabrique des
royaumes là on fait du sirop d'érable
prenez une pause s'il vous plaît faites
une enquête regardait ce que est ce qui
est ce que c'est logique
est-ce qu'ils auraient abus de pouvoir
une enquête c'est aussi ce que réclame
l'union paysanne qui défend les
récalcitrants et le ministre de
l'agriculture pierre paradis nous a dit
qu'il étudiait le dossier très
sérieusement des gardiens de sécurité à
la cabane ce n'est pas exactement
l'image souhaitée